صبرهم وصمودهم
الاسطوري يقدمون
التضحيات ويعلنون الثبات على ارضهم في
مواجهه عدوان الاحتلال واجرامه
ومخططاته فشعبنا العظيم المتسلح بكل معاني
العزه والكرامه والكبرياء
والنضال يثبت للاعداء وللاصدقاء ايضا انه
شعب عصي على الانكسار بفضل الله ولا يعرف
في قاموس نضاله ولا حياته كلمه
الاستسلام وعلى الرغم من العدوان وحرب
الاباده الجماعيه التي يشنها الاحتلال
النازي الا ان هذا الشعب لازال يعلن تمسكه
بارضه والتفافه حول مقاومته
وانتصاره
لها تعجز كل عبارات الفخر والاعتزاز
والاشاده بهذا الشعب ان تفيه حقه وهو
الصامد على ارضه وهو الذي يعبر عن عنوان
نصر وبطوله وتضحيه وثبات ونضال فهو يدافع
عن قضيه عادله وحقوق مشروعه ويدافع عن
كرامتي وشرفي وعزه ومقدسات هذه
الامه هذه المقدسات التي يريد عدونا
النازي والداعمون له تصفيتها وتغييب وطمس
معالمها فيما يحفظها ويبذل في سبيل ذلك كل
التضحيات شعبنا
الفلسطيني لن ينجح اعداؤنا في تحقيق اي من
اهدافهم ومخططاتهم العدوانيه باذن
الله كل ذلك بفضله عز وجل ثم بصمود شعبنا
وبساله
مقاومتنا بل وسنحقق نصرنا ونصرا مبينا ان
شاء
الله ابدا بالحديث حول الوضع الانساني في
قطاع
غزه فمع مواصله الاحتلال النازي حرب
التجويع والتعطيش
الممنهجه في قطاع غزه بات اليوم اكثر من
800 ال فلسطيني من ابناء شعبنا يعيشون
مجاعه
حقيقيه اذ يمنع الاحتلال ادخال المساعدات
او المواد الغذائيه والتموين والوقود
والغاز بل ويمنع الامدادات
الضروريه لاستمرار الحياه الطبيعيه
للناس كما يعيش النازحون من ابناء شعبنا
في محافظات قطاع غزه المختلفه ماساه
حقيقيه لا يمكن وصفها او التعبير عنها
بالكلمات فقد انعدمت كل مقومات الحياه
الطبيعيه هناك بل حتى ان عدم الماوى في
كثير من الاحوال وبلغت الاصابات بسبب
امراض معديه ناتجه عن النزوح 400000 اصابه
بين ابناء شعبنا وارتفعت اعداد الجرحى من
ابناء شعبنا في قطاع غزه فتجاوزت 60,000
جريحا وهم رغم قله الدواء والعلاج محرومون
من السفر للعلاج خارج قطاع غزه في ظل
جرائم الاحتلال التي اخرجت معظم مستشفيات
القطاع عن الخدمه بل وعطلت حتى عيادات
العلاج
الاولي
ويبلغ المفقودون 7000 او يزيد اكثر من 70%
منهم من النساء والاطفال الذين ما زالوا
تحت الانقاض تعجز طواقم الدفاع
المدنيه والطواقم الطبيه عن انتشالهم لضعف
الامكانات نتيجه استهدافها من قبل العدو
ونتيجه استمرار القصف العشوائي المستمر من
الاحتلال وايضا نتيجه غياب الوقود اللازم
لتشغيل هذه
الاليات لم يترك هذا الاحتلال
النازي اي جريمه بشعه مما عرف في تاريخ
النازيه الا وارتكب ضد قطاع غزه خلال ما
يزيد عن 100 يوم كامله قصفا وتدميرا
وتطهيرا عرقيا واباده جماعيه اذ نفذ هذا
الاحتلال حتى الان اكثر من 2000 مجزره ضد
المدنيين والنساء والاطفال خلفت ما يزيد
على 31 الفا من الشهداء
والمفقودين فيما يواصل ذات الكيان عدوانه
واستهدافه واغتياله
للمقاومين في مخيمات ضفتنا ضفه
العياش فقد استهدف صباح اليوم هذا الجيش
النازي مخيمي نور شمس وطولكرم في محافظه
طولكرم ما ادى الى اغتيال عدد من
المجاهدين والمقاومين واستهدف المستشفيات
وسيارات
الاسعاف بالقصف والاغلاق وقام صباح اليوم
باختطاف جثامين ثلاثه من الشهداء الذين
ارتقوا في مخيم بلاطه في محافظه نابلس
ووصل عدد شهداء الضفه اكثر من
377 شهيدا منذ بدايه معركه طوفان الاقصى
ما يؤكد ان
الضفه لا تزال تواصل دورها المقاومه في
الاشتباك مع الاحتلال ومستوطنيه ولن
يردعها او يرعبها او يثنيها القتل
والاغتيال عن القيام بواجباتها افرادا
وفصائل
ومؤسسات ذلك ان معركه طوفان الاقصى هي
معركه وطنيه تعني كل فلسطين وتعني قضيه
فلسطين ومستقبلها واننا نؤكد هنا ضروره
مواصله وتصعيد الاشتباك مع الاحتلال
وتكبيده كل خسائر ممكنه في ظل هذا الوضع
الانساني الكارثي واستمرار جرائم الاحتلال
التي لم يشهد لها التاريخ المعاصر مثيلا
في الوحشيه والاباده الجماعيه نؤكد ما يلي
ان استمرار الاحتلال في هذه الجرائم
والمجازر وال والتقتيل والتجويع والتعطيش
ضد ابناء شعبنا في غزه ومنع ادخال
المساعدات رغم قرار مجلس الامن الدولي
يمثل وصمه عار تاريخيه لكل المتقاعسين
والمتخاذلين الذين امتنعوا حتى اللحظه عن
تجريم هذا الكيان ووقف مجازره ومنع قتل
المدنيين الابرياء بكل اشكال للقتل
الممكنه ونحمل هنا الاداره الامريكيه
ورئيسها بايدن مسؤوليه هذه الجرائم وحرب
الاباده الجماعيه لدعمها هذا الاحتلال
سياسيا ودبلوماسيا وعسكريا فهه الاداره
شريكه فيتل شعبنا وتهجيره وادت ولن تكون
بمعزل عن المسائله
والمحاكمه قانونيا واخلاقيا وسياسيا
اننا امام هذا حول هذه
الكارثه الانسانيه المتفاقم في قطاع غزه
وحاله الجوع والعطش والمرض التي وصل اليها
شعبنا نتساءل كما تتساءل شعوب امتنا
واحرار العالم ماذا تنتظر دولنا العربيه
والاسلاميه حتى تتحرك بشكل جاد وعاجل في
مواجهه كل الضغوط التي يمارسها الاحتلال
والاداره الامريكيه وان تفرض ارادتها في
اغاثه المكلومين من ابناء غزه وتضميد
جراحهم والوقوف والتضامن معهم ان منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي وجامعه الدول العربيه
مدعوان الى كسر الحصار عن قطاع غزه بشكل
عاجل وفوري واجبار الاحتلال على دخول كل
المواد الطبيه والاغاثه ومعدات الاسعاف
فاع المدني الى مناطق غزه كافه وهنا نرحب
باعلان رئيس الاتحاد العالمي لعلماء
المسلمين اعتزامه الدخول الى غزه على راس
وفد من علماء الامه وقياده قافله الاغاثه
والمساعدات لكسر الحصار والتضامن مع شعبنا
في غزه املين ان ينجح في
ذلك اما على الصعيد المسار
الميداني فلا تزال كتائب اب الشهيد عز
الدين القسام المضفره وسرايا القدس ومعهم
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تدير معركه طوفان
الاقصى بقوه وحكمه واقتدار تثع لدماء
شعبنا
وتثخينه
النخبه التي احالتها كتائبنا الى اشلاء
تنسف بذلك كل يوم احلام سيطره الكيان على
ارض غز
وتحقق ما اعلنته من اليوم الاول ان هذه
الارض ستكون مقبره للغزاه وانها بجهادها
ستفتح بوابه تحرير ارضنا كامله ان شاء
الله ان التلاحم الوطني الكبير بين ابناء
شعبنا في الصبر والتضامن والتضحيه والنضال
يؤكد مجددا ان هذا الشعب يلتف حول مقاومته
يحتضنها ويؤمن ان ان مشروعه الحقيقي هو
مشروع المقاومه الشامله وان خياره
الاستراتيجيه لانتزاع الحقوق وتحرير الارض
والمقدسات هو المقاومه وانها اي المقاومه
هي قاعده الوحده الوطنيه التي يعرف بها
الانتماء الوطني لا غير وان وقف العدوان
الصهيوني وردعه عن ارتكاب جرائمه المتوحشه
والنازيه ضد شعبنا في غزه والضفه لا ياتي
الا عبر تصعيد المقاومه بكافه اشكالها
فالمطلوب اليوم هو ان يقف الكل الوطني صفا
واحدا في مواجهه الاحتلال وناز ته التي
تستهدف القضيه ارضا وشعبا ومقدسات وكيانا
سياسيا واذ نبارك عمليات المقاومه
البطوليه في عموم ضفتنا الابيه واخرها
عمليه رع نان البطوليه ونشد على ايدي
المقاومين في جنين ونابلس واريحا وبيت لحم
والخليل وطولكرم وكل المدن والقرى في ضفه
العياش فاننا نؤكد ضروره تصعيد الثوره
وعمليات المقاومه وندعو هنا افراد الاجهزه
الامنيه والامن الوطني الفلسطيني الى
الانضمام الى اخوانهم في المقاومه وتوجيه
السلاح الذي يحملون بايديهم الى جيش
الاحتلال وقطعان المستوطنين الذين
استباحوا الدياره وانتهكوا المحرمات والا
فمتى
سيفعلون ان تسويق الاحتلال والاداره
الامريكيه لما يسمى بالمرحله الثالثه من
العدوان انما يهدف الى تجميل صوره هذا
العدوان النازي ويؤكد اصرار الطرفين على
مواصله جريمه الاباده الجماعيه بحق
شعبنا هنا لابد من الاشاره ان حكومه
الاحتلال النازيه وجيشها المهزوم قد وصلت
الى طريق مسدود لا افق له ولا نهايه في
هذه المعركه لصالحه ابدا والخلافات
الداخليه تتصاعد بين اقطاب حكومه العدوان
النازيه وبين مكونات هذا الشارع الصهيوني
وتتزايد حاله الارتباك والتخبط وعدم الثقه
في هذه الحكومه وفي الجيش بل ويزداد
اليقين بان الهدف الذي رفع تحت عنوان
هزيمه حماس او كسر صمود شعبنا انما هو
اضغاث
احلام ومن المؤكد ان كل يوم جديد يتواصل
فيه العدوان والقصف على شعبنا يمثل تهديدا
حقيقيا على حياه الاسرى لدى
المقاومه اما على صعيد المواقف الدوليه
فاننا اولا نجدد رفضنا وادانت العضوان
الصهيونيه على لبنان الشقيق ونؤكد ايضا
ادانتنا للعدوان الامريكي البريطاني
السافر على اليمن الشقيق كذلك لدعمهما
لشعبنا وتاييده ما لنضاله وحقوقه المشروعه
ونشيد بمواقف الاخوه في انصار الله والجيش
اليمني في استمرار خطواتهم الشجاعه
والجريئه في فرض حصار بحري على الكيان
الصهيوني المجرم كما نعبر عن رفضنا وادانت
واستنكارا الشديد لمواقف المانيا
الاتحاديه في دعم الاحتلال النازي وعدوانه
على شعبنا من خلال الاعلان عن دعم الكيان
الصهيوني في مواجهه القضيه المرفوعه ضده
من دوله جنوب افريقيا امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه وايضا بتوجهها للموافقه على ارسال
نحو 100 الا قضي فه دبابه دعما عسكريا
وشراكه في جريمه الاباده الجماعيه ضد
شعبنا ان حكومه المانيا الاتحاديه بهذه
الشراكه في جريمه الاباده الجماعيه لن
تكفر عن ماضيها النازي وعن ماضي اسلاف
النازيين بل انها في الحقيقه تستعيد
التاريخ النازيه في ابشع صوره وترسم
لالمانيا صوره نازيه جديده ضد شعبنا ان
اننا ندعو حكومه جمهوريه المانيا
الاتحاديه الى التراجع عن هذه السياسه
الخاطئه وان توقف كل اشكال الدعم والتاييد
للعدوان والاجرام الصهيوني وان تتبنى خيار
رفض وتجريم حرب الاباده الصهيونيه ضد
شعبنا وان تتخذ تدابير عاجله ضمن منظومه
الاتحاد الاوروبي من اجل وقف هذا العدوان
واغاثه شعبنا ودعم في نضاله من اجل تحرير
ارضه
ووطنه اما فيما يتعلق بسعي الاداره
الامريكيه واصرارها على فرض الاجنده
الصهيونيه حول ما بعد العدوان النازيه على
قطاع غزه واخر ذلك تصريح جيك سوليفان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي في ظل
استمرار هذا العدوان وحجم القتل والمجازر
والدماء
والاباده فانما اعتبر هذه التصريحات
تعبيرا عن افلاس سياسي واخلاقي لدى هذه
الاداره وهي تاكيد للتورط والشراكه
الحقيقيه في حرب خاسره ضد شعبنا ومحاوله
يائسه لادماج كيان مجرم قاتل الاطفال
والنساء في جسم امتنا ومنطقتنا ان على جيك
سليفن والاداره الامريكيه التي يعمل
لصالحها ان يدرك ان ات نا لا تفرق بين
المسجد الاقصى والمسجد النبوي الشريف
والمسجد الحرام وترى انها جميعا سواء وان
من ينتهك حرمه واحد منها او يقبل بذلك
انما يقبل بانتهاك حرمه غيرها ولا ترى
امتنا كذلك ان قتل الشعب الفلسطيني وان
قتله الشعب الفلسطيني يمكن ان يكونوا
اصدقاء لشعب عربي اخر ان الهدوء والامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه لا يمكن ان ياتي
الا عبر الوقف الفوري والنهائي للعدوان ضد
شعبنا وانهاء الاحتلال لارضنا
ومقدساتنا ومحاسبه قاده الكيان الصهيوني
النازيين على جرائمهم امام المحاكم
الدوليه وتمكين شعبنا من اقامه دولته
المستقله كامله السياده وعاصمتها القدس
اما الحديث عن سعي الولايات المتحده ودول
غربيه لتشكيل حكومه
فلسطينيه جديده فاننا نجدد التاكيد وبوضوح
ان تشكيل اي حكومه فلسطينيه واداره الوضع
الفلسطيني بكل تفاصيله هو شان وطني
فلسطيني خالص نديره مع اخواننا واشقائه من
ابناء القوى والفصائل المختلفه لا شان
لامريكا او غيرها به ولن نقبل ان يتدخل في
شاننا احد ايا كان اختم بالدعاء بالرحمه
للشهداء والشفاء العاجل الجرحى والحريه
باذن الله للاسرى والمعتقلين في سجون
العدو والنصر
لشعبنا ومقاومتنا وانه لجهاد نصر او
استشهاد السلام عليكم حاج اين وصلت
مقاولات وقت اطلاق النار وعمل
تبادل ال الكل يعلم ربما سبق وتحدثنا فيما
يتعلق
بمفاوضات قلنا ان اي
عمليه لاطلاق الاسرى لابد ان تستند الى
وقف كامل وشامل للعدوان على قطاع غزه
وتلقينا بعض الافكار والمبادرات عبر
الاشقاء في مصر وقطر كوسطاء
وبالتشاور مع القوى المقاومه قدمنا تصورا
ل
التعامل مع هذه الافكار
وتم نقله للاشقاء في قطر ومصر وهذا التصور
يحقق ما نريد
وايضا يفضي في نهايه الامر الى انجاز
التبادل بشكل ترضاه المقاومه ويرضاه شعبنا
واضح ان هناك مماطله من قبل الكيان
الصهيوني في هذا الموضوع اي وواضح لدينا
ان ا حكومه الحرب الصهيونيه تحاول استخدام
الملف دون السعي للوصول الى اي حلول هي
تحاول كسب الوقت قدر الامكان لاستمرار
العدوان وتحاول ارتكاب مزيد من الجز
الجرائم والمجازر ولكنها بكل الاحوال على
ما يبدو حتى الان لا يعنيها لا حجم
الجرائم بحجم بحق شعبنا ولا حجم الخسائر
في جنود جيش الاحتلال ولا حتى الخسائر في
صفوف الاسرى لدى المقاومه التي الذين
تتشدق حكومه نتنياهو بحرصها عليهم وسعيها
لاطلاق
سراحهم ممكن تعطينا شويه تفاصيل اكر
الاتفاق تخول الادويه قطع
غزه الحقيقه ربما انا تكلمت
في المؤتمر الماضي عن هذا
الموضوع نحن على مدى 103 ايام خلت كنا
نرعى شؤون الاسرى كما هي عادتنا ثقافتنا
اخلاقنا قيمنا اي ومن هذه الرعايه بعضهم
يحتاج الى ادويه وعلاج من انواع مختلفه
وكان هذا يقدم من ضمن ما هو موجود من
ادويه في ظل الحصار الذي تفرضه حكومه
الاحتلال والولايات المتحده على الدواء اي
هذه الادويه بدات تنضب اي وبدا تفقد
ويتعرض الكل للمعاناه
اي نحن قلنا ان شعبنا لا يمكن ان نقدم
احدا عليه وبالتالي اذا كان هناك اي
مبادره لارسال دواء لابد ان تشمل شعبنا
وان يكون المقدم فيها الشعب الفلسطيني
الاشقاء في قطر بادروا مشكورين لارسال
الدواء
و حكومه فرنسا اي ساهمت في هذا مساهمه
جزئيه واعتقد انه المنطق هنا يطرح سؤالا
مهما لماذا يسال الجميع عن
حاجه اشخاص لا يزيد عددهم عن
عشرات للدواء ولا يتوقف احد امام حاجه
مئات الالاف من الفلسطينيين للدواء هل هذا
العالم وصلت به الجراه والنفاق الى هذا
الحد انه لا يعبا بموت الا في الفلسطينيين
اطفال خدج لنقص الرعايه ونقص
الاكسجين مرضى القلب لنقص الادويه عمليات
تجرى بدون تخدير مرضى يموتون لعدم فرصه
توفير حد ادنى من العلاج لهم اي فيما يقف
العالم على ساق واحده من اجل توفير العلاج
لعدد من الاسرى الصهاينه ان هذا السؤال
الكبير الذي يجب ان يطرح لماذا لا يعبا
العالم بمليونين و300 ال فلسطيني
ومعاناتهم الصحيه فيما يحاول ان يقف على
ساق واحده لصالح عدد من الاسرى الصهاينه
نحن معنيون بالحفاظ على ارواح الجميع لكن
على العالم ان يقدم اجابته بكل الاحوال
نحن نامل ان يعطل نتنياهو هذا التفاهم
لانه على ما يبدو بات واضحا ان مهمه
المقاومه الحفاظ على حياه الاسرى ومهمه
نتنياهو وهدف ف قل هؤلاء الاسراء بكل
طريقه ممكنه حصل عمليه اطلاق رشك الواري
من جنوب لبنان لكتاب الفصان وتم استشهاد
واصابه عدد من كواد الكسون ماذا تعليكم
على
ذلك انا لا يوجد لدي اي تفاصيل حول
الموضوع اي العاده والعرف عندنا ان من
يتبنى او من يعلن عن هذه التفاصيل هو
كتائب القسام حتى يتم الاعلان بشكل واضح
لا يمكن تعليق على اي تفاصيل في هذا
الموضوع لكن بكل الاحوال الشعب الفلسطيني
شعب مقاوم وهو شعب يتصدى لعدوان هو الاكبر
في تاريخ القضيه الفلسطينيه منذ عام
48 وهذا الشعب يبذل جهده حيث ما استطاع
وكيف ما استطاع للمقاومه ومن الطبيعي ان
يكون في اي مواجهه مع هذا العدو شهداء
وجرحى ومن الطبيعي ايضا ان تكون خاتمه هذه
المواجهه انتصار باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى
شكرا
لكم ش